Jeff Cavaliere was one of the first
people to enter the fitness industry on
YouTube having posted his first video
over 10 years ago in March of 2009 over
the past decade he has slowly but
consistently built a massive audience on
YouTube
standing at ten point four million
subscribers today by now
we all know that youtubers with 10
million subscribers plus are stacked
making several million per year but this
is nothing compared to how much Jeff
pulls in with athlean-x as jeff is not
only one of the top paid code is on
YouTube but quite possibly the top paid
coach in the world so here's how much
Jeff Cavaliere makes to athlean-x
[Music]
starting off jeff has two main streams
of income which are YouTube Adsense and
of course his core sales to calculate
his YouTube ad revenue we'll first
estimate his CPM or the money he
received per thousand views we can
actually do this pretty accurately as a
few fitness youtubers have actually
revealed their earnings Matt does
Fitness revealed that he made thirty
three thousand six hundred sixty-eight
dollars off a fifteen point eight
million views which comes out to a CPM
of $2.13 one thing to note is that this
is already Matt's final CPM as the
revenue amount already comes for
YouTube's portion as well as ads not
playing on certain views in other words
$2.13 is what Matt gets at the entered a
per thousand views but that's just one
video so overall CPM for Fitness could
be higher or lower Matt does go over a
few more videos who CPMs are also in the
same ballpark but an even more accurate
view of fitness YouTube Adsense is
Branton Campell demon who revealed his
overall earnings over an entire year
using his views and earnings figures we
get a CPM of 2011 cents so this confirms
that Fitness see PM's range between $2
and 2025 cents well say that athlean-x
gets on a lower end of this range at $2
per thousand views to keep it
conservative now athlean-x has had a bit
of a spike in views recently because of
the pandemic as more people are sitting
at home and looking for viable workout
solutions however looking at the reviews
over the past three years we can see
that they have averaged about 30 million
views per month this itself would bring
in 60,000 dollars per month in ad
revenue or 720 thousand dollars per year
this is already an astounding income but
this is just the beginning
moving on to their courses they offer 13
different courses for most of these the
fee structure is the same you can pay
seventy seven dollars and fifty cents to
have access to the program for 120 days
or you can shell out another twenty
dollars and keep it forever the only
programs that break this formula are the
special tactics and women's training
program this special tactics program is
significantly shorter so it only cost
$50 while the woman's training program
is actually a bit more expensive at $90
but 11 out of their 13 programs follow
the standard pricing scheme so it's
likely that their average order price is
between 77 and $97 to keep it
conservative again while estimating the
lower end of this range at $80 per order
next we have to figure out how many
orders athlean-x is actually getting
sponsored videos typically have a
click-through rate of 4 to 7 percent now
that's where classic wake dashlane and
curiosity stream plugs and videos
usually those sponsored content is
related to the video you're watching
it's not from the Creator itself however
with athlean-x the courses in the
description are made by the same guy
Jeff Cavaliere so their CTR is likely
higher than the average but we'll stick
to the average to illustrate how much
money Jeff is making at the very minimum
so out of the 100 people who watch this
video let's say only 4 people go on to
his website and check out his courses or
basically a 4% CTR which is the bottom
of the average range ask for how many
people who visit his website actually
buy his course the average global online
conversion rate is 2.8 6% now again that
number is mostly based on online
services like Wix as well as physical
products like monitors or speakers
people going on to the athlean-x website
already like Jeff's workouts and are
looking for a more long-term structured
program so his conversion rates are also
likely higher than average but even at a
below average 2.5 percent conversion
rate this would mean that one out of
every 1,000 viewers would actually buy a
program you can quickly see why this
would be a lot of money when you have 30
million monthly viewers as that would
come out to 30,000 monthly orders at 80
dollars a pop his courses were generated
2.4 million dollars per month or a
whopping 28 point eight million dollars
per year adding this with the Adsense
Coach Cavalier is pulling in at least 29
point 5 million dollars per year through
athlean-x
ask for his expenses well this is the
beauty of an online business
there aren't many expenses of course we
know he has Jesse maybe a couple of
people to edit and upload videos a
couple people to manage a website a
cameraman but that's pretty much it even
if you had 10 employees and paid them
each $10,000 per month this will only
cost him 1.2 million per year let's
throw in another 300k for his gym
service for his website computers and so
on and so forth this would leave Jeff
with a profit of 28 million dollars per
year before taxes the corporate tax rate
in America has been 21% for a few years
at this point
so after taxes his net profit would be
22 point 1 2 million dollars call it 20
million now let's remember that this is
after using below average click-through
rates and conversion rates
overestimating expenses and cutting off
millions just to be conservative
furthermore we didn't take into account
repeat customers or a Spanish Channel
which also pulls in several million
views per month using a 7% CDR 3 percent
conversion rate and accounting for a
Spanish Channel after the same expenses
and taxes Jeff would be left with 57
point seven million dollars now as for
how much his entire company's worth on
the stock market companies are generally
Awards 10 to 20 times their earlier
earnings with the average actually been
higher than that right now at 23 point
one five with twenty million dollars in
profit per year and a price to earnings
ratio of ten athlean-x will be worth two
hundred million dollars but with an
annual profit of fifty seven point seven
million dollars Enterprise to earnings
of their current market average of 23
point one five athlean-x would actually
be a billion dollar company at one point
three three five billion of course
that's a really big range but that's
simply because we use the lowest
possible and highest possible numbers
looking right in the middle with a forty
million dollar annual net profit in a
p/e ratio of fifteen athlean-x is likely
worth about six hundred million dollars
so Jeff Cavaliere is balling over here
as he is the owner of a six hundred
million dollar business making
40 million per year he easily morphs
that top paid coaches in the world
making tens of millions more and will
become a billionaire in the coming years
if he's not won already
but then again Jeff isn't just a coach
but more importantly a business owner it
seems like the key to being number one
in your field is being named to Jeff in
all seriousness though Jeff Cavaliere
has been working at this for over a
decade and provides so much value
whether you're watching his free videos
on YouTube were purchasing as a value
pack all week program from their website
so it's no wonder he's so successful but
it is still very impressive that he was
able to accomplish all of this on
YouTube I think he may just be the
number one pick reader on the platform
do you guys think anyone Topsham make
sure to comment that down below also
drop a like if you guys appreciate the
depth of this analysis and consider
subscribing see more questions logically
answered but until then I'm hari I'll
see you guys on the next one